normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government let's
jump to this story from the American
Survey Center looks like it's a American
Enterprise Institute Generation Z and
the transformation of American
adolescence how jz's formative
experiences shape its politics
priorities and future and I need only
throw it to Matthew eaus so we can give
you the breakdown of what they of the
one of the most important things they
found lo and behold my friends gen Z
support for same-sex marriage drops from
21 from 2021 to
2023 in 2021 genz 80% supported same-sex
marriage today it is 69% lower than
Millennials higher than genx and higher
than Boomers but lower than Millennials
now that's really really interesting
Millennials approval for samesex
marriage went up Generation X went up
and Boomers went up and gen Z went down
so what Matthew aaas says is that it's
probably a fluke however he goes on to
say I I do think we now have a good
amount of evidence that Zoomers are
going to be more conservative than
Millennials but this particular finding
is just really fishy sure that may be
but the data shows it and we have that
uh right now but we can see that there's
there interestingly I'll tell you
exactly why I think this happening take
a look at this jz's unique teen
experiences percentage of Americans who
report participating in or experiencing
the following in their teen years
gen Z regularly attended religious
Services 52% Millennials 58 Gen X 64
Boomer 71 jenzi is down in religious
experiences had a part-time job 58%
Millennials 70 genx 79 Boomers 82 had a
boyfriend or girlfriend
56% once again Millennials 69 76 78
drank alcohol or smoked pot or
cigarettes occasionally gen Z absolutely
not smoking and drinking and then felt
lonely or isolated
61% Millennials 57 generation x 44
Boomer 36 you want to know why it is
that gen Z probably had a huge push back
against same-sex marriage in the past
two years it's it's laid out exactly
right here they are lonely they are
isolated they don't have significant
others and they're feeling like this
weird neow woke whatever you want to
call it world this cultural world is
causing them relationship problems they
don't see in the older Generations so
interestingly gen Z looks to Millennials
Gen X and Boomers and they're probably
thinking how come they were able to do
it what's going on today is bullish and
it sucks and then the old generation who
has it are like we should be more
accepting and Progressive causing
problems for the young people I also
think outside of all of this the biggest
and most important component here
is liberals don't have kids and 20 years
ago when jenz was being created in
passionate love
making more conservatives had kids than
liberals and that means there are more
geny conservatives and liberals that's
well conservatives weren't killing their
kids at Mass like liberals do Li
liberals not only don't have kids they
abort their kids they're now getting
into uh practices which can result in
the sterilization of their kids
conservatives are still having less kids
for sure but I I tell people when they
say oh indoctrination and it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter because
two two reasons
one more conservative kids no matter
what means more conservative Future No
Matter What there's only so much
indoctrinating can do and it can
convince people it can change people but
it can't be as pronounced as literal
biological reality of human beings who
are created in conservative spaces so
like the indoctrination needs to take
place in areas where the left has
control or has taken control but
conservatives are pushing back in the
culture War which means they're losing
but more importantly the one of the most
important things outside of biological
reality is the economic reality even the
child of a leftist family is now
wondering why it is they can't find a
boyfriend or girlfriend they can't find
a job and they feel so lonely and
they're looking around them and saying
everything we have is worse than what it
used to be and so you're going to get
people who are going to keep saying
return but with the V you know what I
mean I love this chart because it just
tells you the Baby Boomers were out
living life and then we restricted lock
and plugged in gen Z I mean every
generation here got progressively more
online and gen Z was the first
generation to live through a lockdown
because probably more of them no but
these these experiences the culture the
community are really valuable things
they shape who people are and so the
idea that gen Z is worse off is because
they are actually isolated right they
are unhappy and so they're looking
around and saying we talked about this
once the fact that genz especially
you'll see it on Tik Tok they're
obsessively trying on different fashion
trends from from decades before and
they're saying we wanted what you guys
had we're trying to find what this is
they want the baby boomer life where
they can go out without their cell phone
and go get you know drunk in the woods
with their teenage friends or whatever
kids did because they can't do these
things because their life is perpetually
online and they have no social Community
well you see how cancerous the dating
pools are nowadays too this not had a
boyfriend or girlfriend I'm sorry but
the bab Boomers didn't have the
situation ship you know what I mean like
they actually did something about it I I
have the answer for genen Z listen if
you if you are wondering go to church
it's crazy I did not I went to church
when I was a kid stopped going around 12
never went again but I am telling you
it's not about just like some faith in
God or anything it is about being part
of a community that looks out for each
other and if you don't want to do that
that's fine you need to find a community
and build one up see the issue is for
the Boomers 71% were going to religious
services so of course they they were
able to have a boyfriend or girlfriend
of course they did not feel as lonely or
isolated surprisingly they drank and
smoke way more and this is pot or
alcohol or okay or cigarettes so they're
probably all smoking cigarettes to be
fair but the the reality is when you
look at this chart religious regularly
attending religious Services means they
are constantly in a social
environment and jenz less likely to do
so it was crazy I saw this video it went
viral like a year ago of this moderately
attractive like 24-year-old woman
talking about how she was basically an
incel she stayed at home all day she had
no boyfriend and she posted things on
the internet and I'm like that's weird
like I can understand that for a
24-year-old guy who does not know how to
do these things but I was like surprised
to learn man even for young women
they're experiencing many of these
similar things because it's not about
whether you're a man or a woman for the
most part it's whether or not you know
how to socialize or you are a terminally
online person mhm it's almost like
skewing gender roles is a bad thing for
dating it's almost like women are
supposed to be women and men are
supposed to be men and we have a
mutually beneficial relationship and
when you start to skew that it makes
people more lonely I mean no man is
going to go hang out with another man
that was a woman and you're not going to
seek that exact same relationship I mean
some of you might but it doesn't work
out I think it progresses into marriage
too right I mean as soon as we sent
women to the workforce we saw complete
collapse in their more traditional roles
like uh Vol volunteering went down this
is typically something women man in the
home it's typically women who organize
the social calendar and so if you have
two working people who are obsessed all
the time plugged in their laptop job the
idea that there's community that they
Foster among themselves and among their
children just completely goes away
people don't take people don't realize
how important the gender roles were for
society they think it's just something
that happened to oppress women take a
look at this one jenz adults spent less
time with friends as teenagers this is
crazy to me Jen X 60% said during most
or all of my team years they hung out
with friends 29% said during some of
their teen years and 11% said not at all
only 40% of jenz says during most or all
of their teen years they regularly hang
out with hung out with friends that's
that's crazy my mine is uh uh if if
someone asked me during all of my teen
years all I did was regularly hang out
with my friends yo there there were
points in my life when I was like 14 I
wouldn't go home I would stay over at my
friend's house all night and we'd play
N64 like the four of us we were in I had
friends we were in a band together then
I started skateboarding my friend group
got bigger all we would do is go out and
skateboard all the time and then when I
stopped going to high school after a
couple months all we did was go out
every single day in skateboard it is
crazy to me to think that there are
there there were kids and jenz that
literally were not hanging out with
friends but think about the effect of Co
right the internet and Co there was
literally years that high schoolers went
from being like like I know people who
were freshmen in high school the year
lockdown happened right then for the
next basically two
years yeah they'd be gen Z yeah and so
they wouldn't be in school I mean this
is true of a lot of people and if you're
not I mean this is true in a lot of
situations you have to start making
friends to in order to maintain
friendship so if they never got that
introduction especially during this age
where socializing is actually something
the brain desperately needs to practice
then you are chat it's more challenging
to make friends it gets more comfortable
to stay online and talk on Anonymous you
know internet forums whatever else the
the internet is good in a lot of ways
but ultimately I think a lot of people
have been using it to avoid practicing
normal social skills that baby boomers
just did because that was how we
operated as a society this is crazy take
a look at this so uh influence on
Parental
education kids who had two parents were
more likely substantially more likely to
take private art or music lessons
playing a competitive sport regularly
attend religious services and
substantially less likely to drink
alcohol smoke pot or cigarettes
occasionally unsurprised ing that two
parent homes are better now with no
degree that's college degree which is
interesting two parents with no degree
was uh less likely than single parents
to play competitive sport I think that
one makes sense single parent probably
says I'm going to drop my kid off at
soccer practice so I can go take care of
business and then come back later but
still regularly attended religious
Services still uh less likely to drink
and and smoke pot still more likely to
take a private art or music lessons
single parent across the board seems to
to have it the worst and think that's in
increasing there was a viral post that's
probably fake but it was like a woman
saying she was seeking a sperm donor and
I think I I had a video about this
earlier there's a black market sperm
donation thing happening on Facebook
where women are like I'm trying to get
pregnant so I need a donor and it's just
like it's the weirdest thing this is
what's what what has evolved of
procreation I seriously think we're
going towards pod babies because women
are going be like I'm going to keep my
there's a movie about it I forgot what
it's called but it's like a woman wants
to have a kid but she's a careerist so
she ends up getting a pod where the baby
grows in a thing and they put in the
closet which is a metaphor for mother
motherhood there right she's going to
have it happen somewhere where she's not
actually having to deal with it well you
bring it to work and then you put in the
closet but it's like it's kind of a bad
ending anyway but I think that's
definitely where we're going one of the
uh big trends now is that women are
seeking unvaccinated sperm only but uh
in one of this posts the woman was like
I want to you know I I want a man to
come and don't and donate in person the
natural way and then leave and I'll take
care of the baby on my own this means
that baby has only a mom this is a
recipe for disaster for society thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net